mallorca macht dicht das heißt also
solche bilder werden wir möglicherweise
in diesem sommer nicht mehr sehen
ganz schön sauer werden kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja das waren bilder aus dem megapark so
kennen wir den megapark an der playa de
palma wirklich 10.000 leute feiern
es wird alkohol getrunken und wir hören
das soll es in diesem jahr gar nicht
mehr geben denn die baleareninsel ist
natürlich wegen corona alarmiert und es
gibt da verschiedene pläne der eine
besagt wir starten erst mal mit inlands
touristen also mit spanier vom festland
die werden nach mallorca gelockt mit
günstigen flügen und vielleicht startet
man dann im august sanft mit
auslandstouristen also mit uns deutschen
das sind alles natürlich noch pläne aber
das lässt schlimmes erahnen also
tatsächlich die die insel leidet und wir
wenn wir urlaub gebucht haben wir leiden
natürlich auch und wie haben sie eben
schon im video gesehen immer noch vor
ort und sie hofft natürlich auf
auftritte die ballermann star easy glück
ist da hallo hallo ja wie wird es denn
dann in dieser saison wir hören wirklich
wirklich keine massenpartys ist ist ist
ein gewerbe quasi damit tut was ist los
da ja ich habe ehrlich gesagt bis zur
letzten sekunde gehofft und ich war
immer super optimistischen habt ja wir
werden noch irgendwie eine oder andere
party feiern ist es ja im megapark aber
jetzt so langsam muss man der realität
ins auge blicken also ich bin sehr
traurig dass ich persönlich rechne jetzt
nicht mehr damit dass wir noch eine
saison auf mallorca haben werden 2020
wer weiß vielleicht im september
vielleicht tatsächlich noch mal den
einen oder anderen auftritt aber das
macht mich sehr traurig ja das verstehe
ich also das kann man sich doch gar
nicht vorstellen mallorca ohne party
andererseits wenn man dorthin reisen
kann vielleicht ab august beim feiert
man irgendwie mit sicherheitsabstand
kann ich mir schwer vorstellen kannst du
dir das vorstellen
das habe ich auch schon überlegt also
eine party mit masken und
sicherheitsabstand und desinfizieren ich
meine die partie im megapark ist dadurch
ausgezeichnet dass man eben persönlichen
kontakt hat dass man dicht an dicht mit
den leuten zusammen feiern kann
ich kann es mir schwer vorstellen wie
das dann aussehen soll und schon daher
gespannt und drückt uns trotzdem weiter
die daumen dass wir trotzdem vielleicht
wenigstens noch ein paar wochen in
diesem jahr feiern können irgendwie und
wenn es weniger leute sind und sonst ein
wohnzimmerkonzert genau das geht
vielleicht immer noch tritt zusammen die
dann in deutschland aus oder wie
wie hältst du dich dann darüber wasser
also normalerweise sieht man sommer so
aus dass ich in der regel ja so zwei
drei mal die woche im megapark auftrete
und dann freitags rüber schlägt nach
deutschland und dann habe ich da
irgendwie 45 auftritte pro wochenende in
clubs oder auf festivals die
großveranstaltungen sind ja jetzt auch
schon bis zum 31 08 auf jeden fall
abgesagt das bedeutet die ganzen großen
sommer open air partys seien sowieso
schon mal flach weiter für dieses jahr
ich hoffe dass ich die eine oder andere
party auch als kleinere veranstaltungen
sind vielleicht in diskotheken oder so
schon vielleicht ab juni juli feiern
kann in deutschland und ja da halte ich
mich über wasser mit den auftritten in
deutschland
aber mein herz stück fehlt natürlich
dann wünsche ich dass es nicht ganz so
schlimm wird und dass es dann doch die
eine oder andere partie wie die sie
glück gibt vielen dank